وكانه افرغ على عجل
مع ابن الاوكرانيا الخاص ندخل الى سجن
المحلي في احدى ضواحي خرسون
السلطات الاوكرانيه الروس بتحويله الى
مركز تعذيب قبل انسحابهم من المدينه وتزعم
انها اكتشفت اماكن ومقر عموميه اخرى
استخدمت للغايه نفسها
كل شيء هنا يدلل على ان القوات الروسيه ما
كتت في هذا المكان لفتره من الزمن وفقا
للقوات الاوكرانيه كما تشاهدون على هذا
الجدار كتب بالروسيه النشيد الوطني الروسي
وفي الاعلى كتب بالروسيه ايضا يحيى او
تحيا روسيا يحيى بوتين يحيا وزير الدفاع
الروسي يقول فريق التحقيق الاوكراني انه
عثر على ادوات تعذيب
[موسيقى]
توت خلال فتره الاحتلال احتجز رؤوس هنا
اكثر من 100 شاب اوكراني بعض من احتجزه
وتركوا بعد الانسحاب تحدث الينا كانوا
يسعقونهم بالكهرباء وينقلون بهم
منطقه سكنيه على اطراف المدينه
يسكن في شقه مطله على فناء السجن عايش
دخول الروسي الى الحي قبل تسعه اشهر
وانسحابهم منه اخيرا كنت اسمع وارى كيف
يعذبون الناس في الفناء كان صراخهم عاليا
بعضهم ماتوا من شده الضرب ومن بقي منهم
حيا كان يجبر على تاديه وروسيا
لا يتوقف يوري عن البحث عن ولده يقول انه
اقتدى مع اخرين الى مكان يجهله
[موسيقى]
اسابيع وعندما انسحب الروس اخذه معهم اريد
ان اعرف مصيره امنيتي الوحيده ان يكون حيه
وبينما يتحدث الاوكرانيون عن 400 جريمه
حرب الروسيه في خرسون ومقاطعه اخرى تنفي
روسيا الاتهامات لا بل وتلقي باتهامات
مماثله على اوكرانيا اخرها ما قالت موسكو
انه اقدامه قوات الاوكرانيه على قتلى جنود
روس اثناء استسلامهم التهاب شككت فيه كيف
الجزيره خير